Recording in progress. That's perfect.
And yeah, I welcome you to today's event and today's topic, which is shadow and projection, which is a topic which is pretty well known from Jung, and it's a little bit a term he coined, but it's not completely his because he very often used the terms he's using from other sources like archetypes.
Archetypes, I think they are mentioned in Letters of Cicero first, and things like anima or Logos or Eros. He tried to use more common words to make it understandable, but he did not try to make so strange words that it sounds completely medical and nobody can understand it.
So the shadow, To make it very easy is the thing that is generated by light. When light hits an object and there's an area where light cannot reach it, there's a shadow. So everybody has a shadow as long as that's a light source. And if you have, of course, multiple light sources, you have multiple shadows, which you can see, for example, in a soccer play.
And it's not by accident that he chose that name of shadow. For one thing is this dichotomy, this polarity of light and dark, but also a shadow is very much on the ground and associated with the ground, for instance. I will come to this, what he means with that.
So normally the shadow part, as it is understood, of a personality is a part that people like to repress, that parts that get ignored. So all the uncomfortable stuff, let's say, that are painful, that are regrettable, that are shameful, that are basically repressed, full of guilt.
And repression is a pretty important concept in psychoanalysis. And Jung started out as a psychoanalyst by saying, okay, everything that's incompatible with, let's say, society puts in a special place. And Freud has this special place which is called the unconscious.
And Jung builds on that, that he says, okay, yeah, certain things that get repressed also get to the unconscious, but they get to a pretty special place of the unconscious, which is the personal unconscious. Why personal? For Jung, the world and the psyche is structured with the consciousness in the middle.
This is because this is the center of our living and of our being. There's everything that we know, everything we can do, everything that is touched by light, let's say, which we, we can perceive and manipulate in a willful manner. So everything outside is the unconscious, and that's a lot, and it's, it's dark in the sense that we cannot see it.
And the first things you wade through when you try to approach the unconscious are first the parts you try to get rid of, like all the waste associated with your personality or your experiences, like for example, traumatic experiences or things you are not happy about or things you don't want to accept about yourself, those go into the shadow.
This is the basic premise, let's say. And this is the understanding that most people have of the shadow. It's like, ah, this is a negative personality and everything that is not wanted by consciousness gets dropped there. But Jung goes a little bit further and here it becomes a little bit of a problem that he often has multiple definitions for the same word.
Like unconscious has many different definitions based on the context and shadow also. So sometimes unconscious and shadow are for him treated in the same way. So things get dropped off to the wayside.
And what I mean with that is when consciousness is focused on something and it wants to do something, it's very easy to ignore things. You have to get rid of certain things.
For example, when people have a very strong career focus and they only work, they of course don't nourish strong personal relationships, especially intimate relationships, because time is a problem. So this is why many people that are completely work-oriented get problems later in life. So it works for a certain time, but it starts to build.
And it starts to build in the unconscious because all the stuff you don't take care of, it does not disappear. It goes into a place and that place is the unconscious and there it can gather.
And especially this personal unconscious part of the personal unconscious is where everything is that should be you, should be associated with you. But isn't for certain reasons, because it's regrettable, it's shameful, it's all the stuff people don't want to touch.
But in there, in the dark, in the shadow, can also be all the positive attributes of a person. There's a kind of relationship between always consciousness and unconscious. As the unconscious reacts to consciousness.
It's a receptacle of all the things that consciousness does not want to have, but it's also creating a kind of compensatory counterweight to the attitude and how consciousness is. That becomes a little bit easier to understand when you take into factor the personality model.
Of Jung, which consists of extraversion and introversion, whether you're oriented more to the outside world or inside world. So when you're very extroverted and you're oriented into the outside world, the inside world becomes more unconscious and it's more in the shadow. So if you have a very extroverted shadow, that means you're very introverted then in turn again.
So it's always this counterbalance being created. And Jung has a pretty nice quote about that, that I had here, which is, the shadow is on the one side regrettable and reprehensible weakness, on the other side healthy instinctivity and the prerequisite for higher consciousness.
Because it's not only the dump, let's say, it's in a dump in the sense that unconscious treats all those contents with a discount. It just discounts the value of those things. But consciousness is fragile, has to learn, has to grow, is new. So it's very easy to get rid of things that are important.
When you have no idea what the values of things is, you very likely will throw something away valuable. And for Jung, the— one's individual life path to growth and to living a fulfilled life is to integrate everything that there is to integrate, which of course the first step is the personal unconscious.
So of course the way to grow and the way to be a more complete human being is to go through this very dark part, the dark valley of things that are shameful, regrettable, Things you're not proud of, but also good qualities that you don't realize are good qualities.
So some modern Jungians, for example, speak of the golden shadow in the sense that not to say like, oh, the shadow is only the adversary, it has to be fought, but rather there's an opportunity to grow there. There's an opportunity to develop because the important Things are there.
As I said, consciousness is very small, very fragile, and if it wants to grow, it has to go in the dark places. This, of course, is not such a nice experience because it means confronting the things that are painful to you. He has a further view beyond the personal unconscious. There, the collective part comes. I won't go into deeply there.
But this is the collective part being part of the human nature, which connects one with every human being in the world now and the future, and even down below animals, that their instincts there.
And Jung has an interesting view of the psyche in the sense that sometimes it's very differentiated and the other side he's not. When consciousness experiences the unconscious, he sometimes calls it the other.
And like the first time you really come into contact with the unconscious, it's the top layer of the unconscious, which is the personal unconscious. So everything looks kind of personal. Like everything is related to the things you have experienced, the things you know, or you don't want to know. And everything is presented in this light.
And the shadow, and here comes another definition of the shadow, is then represented as a specific figure, like a person you can interact with. It's like another personality within the psyche that does certain things. And it can pop up.
For example, in dreams or visions, this is not so untypical to encounter one's shadow in one's dreams because dreams are the most subjective experience one can have. And everything that happens in a dream is oneself. And it's like interacting with split-off parts from one's psychology.
And rather than saying like, this is like an instinct on anomalous force that is hard to grasp. Jung says the shadow can be, if it's strong enough, it's been ignored enough, be like a second entity that tries to get into contact with one directly and indirectly.
So on the top surface, it looks like everything is personal. Like if you are extraverted, then it looks like introverted, your shadow is. But below comes everything that is like the collective wisdom of human beings and human culture and human endeavor that can come up.
So the shadow always looks a little bit primitive, a little bit animalistic or inferior. It's It's the unconscious, so not everything is very, very clear. Everything gets mixed and mangled together. But the important point to get here is it's like a negative ego.
It's like if we would take a negative picture of consciousness and everything that consciousness is not is then in the unconscious and first represented as the shadow. And it looks quite incompatible. And this is why most people think of shadow as something negative because It consists of all the negative parts. It's like, oh no, I did not want to have this.
And you put it all in one pile and this pile then becomes alive. And of course, the more you ignore, the more you— things don't get accepted in consciousness. For example, when somebody has bad qualities or did something that is shameful, it all conglomerates. It's not gone. It's a little bit like the second law of thermodynamics. Nothing really gets lost.
Energy does not get lost. It's only transferred or transformed in another form. And the same in the psyche. Nothing gets lost. Somewhere it always is and it can conglomerate in this shadow figure.
It's then this dual function between, yeah, it's a part of you that you ignore, but then it's the rest of the whole psyche and the journey when one takes on the journey of individuation through the psyche, it's first through the shadow, encountering the shadow, dealing with the shadow. And when this is done, then all the other parts come like anima, animus, and Self.
But as I said, I won't go into those because right now we are focusing on the shadow. If, when the shadow gets personified, It's very often of the, oh, like exclusively for Jung in the form of the same-sex person because it's a negative in you, but it's still you.
I'm trying to think of an example. Ah, for example, in Star Wars, we have Luke Skywalker and Darth Vader, and those are adversaries. In the movie or movies. And you can see that everything that Luke Skywalker isn't, Darth Vader is. He's tall, he's calm, he's Master Jedi, he's very frightful.
And Luke Skywalker, he's very young, ambitious, but does not really know how to be a Jedi, and he's uncontrolled. And Vader is very controlled. So they're complementary. They're the same, the different sides of the same coin. They complement each other. And this is a relationship that defines them.
And the shadow is at the same time this compensatory, this compensatory aspect of the same coin. And Sometimes the shadow does not have to be like one person. It can also be multiple persons in dreams, but Jung said that does not happen so often.
It's rather unusual, but it's the thing that the unconscious itself is not really objective. And that's the thing where it's like when you think in the external world and yeah, how the outside world is, it's made full of objects, let's say, and there is very discrete. If I have a table, it's, it's one table, right? If I have a car, it's one car.
Of course I can take it apart and have parts of a car, but if I assemble it back, I have one car. So everything is a little bit more discrete. In the unconscious, it's not.
Things can change very much based on how the consciousness is made up because you perceive also through your consciousness because it determines what you are able to perceive. And this is a pretty hard concept to get to. I have an event called Perception and Experience that tries to get there.
It's a little bit complex, but it's like looking through different glasses and the world that you see becomes twisted and turns, it changes colors and so on. But of course you can remove those glasses, and then it starts looking differently.
The world is maybe the same, but your experience and how you perceive it changes, and it's changing mainly through how your consciousness grows and how it is interacting.
For example, when you become more and more knowledgeable, for example, let's say music, you have no idea about music, you learn about music theory, and you become more and more familiar with what is rhythm, what are what are the notes, what are chords and all these things. Suddenly your experience of a song will be very different based on these different types of proficiency.
And this is why the unconscious is difficult to get down. And this is why it's difficult to say the unconscious is only the shadow. Yeah, you have the shadow, but in reality, the shadow consists of personal stuff, but there's also anima, animus in there.
There's Self in there, there's instincts in there, there are complexes in there, but it's perceived as one thing because the differentiation is not there. So the whole unconscious is represented by this very narrow hole of the shadow. And when you transcend the shadow, suddenly it becomes the anima.
Suddenly all the unconscious, which is all the stuff that's not yet integrated since We have now integrated ego and shadow together into consciousness. Everything looks like, ah, it's the anima. So, but if you integrate the anima, then it becomes the Self and so on.
So how the unconscious is and how it's perceived changes on what development the unconscious, the consciousness have. So in that sense, he said, yeah, it can be even split that you don't perceive one singular thing. But there are several things that are all shadow, but different degrees on how far it's integrated.
He says it happens more in myths and fairy tales than in dreams, but he experienced that. So what does it mean to have a shadow? This is something that was very important to Jung. And I have another quote for you. The man without a shadow thinks himself harmless precisely because he is ignorant of his shadow.
So if you are unaware of the things you can do, of course you think you're a nice person. You were never in the situation where you had to be a bad person.
So I once heard when soldiers that go to war get PTSD, it has very often to do with the fact that they experience themselves doing things in situations that they are not really proud of. And that this is not a controlled manner, but like an automatic manner that something in the psyche takes over.
And it might be even possible that they liked it in the situation. So it's like a stranger in your house that is suddenly appearing and you're thinking, okay, well, what's happening here? Something is not part of my self-image, not part of my house.
Suddenly there are other forces here and people have to reconcile, uh, reconcile with that fact that they have the very extreme experience. So having a shadow is something, let's say, normal because not everything is integrated, as I said, immediately.
And the very ironic thing is As I said, consciousness is an extremely important part of perception. This is why people ignore the shadow because it's easy to ignore and to repress in the sense that you're not aware that you might have negative qualities or things that you're not taking care of.
But in other people, it's immediately the same. And Jung says that, like, you, What you don't see in yourself, others can see immediately when you are in disharmony with yourself, when things are not working together, that something is inside the psyche acting in the person against the will of that person. That's perceivable very easily.
So if one wants, wants to find out what one's shadow is, one only has to ask around, like close friends or relatives. But if they would have to talk about their own shadow, they would say, oh no, everything is fine. I know everything. No, I'm a good person.
But another way to see this is the quote, you see the splinter in the eye of your neighbor, but you won't see the beam of lumber in front of your own eyes. It goes into that. You are way more perceptive for other people's shadow than you are for your own.
And if you want to perceive the shadow of others more easily, there's also a neat trick. Because it's repressed, repression is an act of willpower. So if you reduce the willpower of people, it's pretty, it's easier to gets what's happening below. This means lowering of consciousness. What lowers consciousness?
When people are sleepy, when they're drunk, when they're ill, when they're stressed. So this is very often where we would say to experience the other person's real character.
And there's even this saying, like when you want to marry someone or be in a long-term relationship with someone, You should be around them when they've been very ill at least once or when they've been under extreme stress because then all this stuff comes out. And I experienced this myself.
There are some people that is not fun really to get drunk with them, to get, or let's say just go drinking because suddenly they change their character. And then the question is really, okay, who are you really? The person that is sober or the persona when you're drunk.
So especially when you, I had it in my school time and study times, there were some people who were like acting up completely different just because they've been drinking. So interesting experience. And this is then how you can see these repressed contents suddenly acting up. And people that have a shadow.
And as I said, the more you ignore this stuff, the stronger it gets. They tend to go into an extreme direction to hide the fact that they have a shadow. It's not like that they're consciously aware of it. It's just an unconscious drive to be drawn to certain activities.
For example, when somebody is criminal, this is an example from Jung, they try to appear as law-abiding and normal as possible, that you would not suspect that.
Or when people have big psychological trouble, that they're trying to act as normal as possible, that they seem like a character of caricature of a normal person. It's like a textbook example, but it's like no person is only that. A person has a whole personality. Everybody has a whole personality, a whole psychology.
So if you only see one side of the personality of a person, you can be damn sure there's a lot of stuff hidden. And even to the person itself, it's just that they feel this undying urge to be a certain way, like being extremely generous while on the other side complaining that other people are not generous.
Because they see rather their own shadow projected onto other people. And this brings us to the next part, the second part of this events topic. And this is projection. And this is important factor, again, also from psychoanalysis, but also for the understanding how consciousness perceives.
Because Carl Gustav Jung says, Just because you don't perceive something in yourself does not mean again that it's really gone. It's in the unconscious, but that does not mean that it's highly neatly hidden away, but rather it's now projected all out in the world.
And projection in this sense means how you perceive the world. And I want to get one step back to have some basic premises regarding projection. So for Jung, projection is like a completely normal process that's happening. It's just a function of the psyche and how we perceive and how we experience the world.
For him, it's like a layer of interpretation of value put on top of the world. He says, if you look in the physical world, you have, we have wavelengths. Right?
So that's, you have that everywhere, electromagnetic wavelengths, and it can be a microwave, it can be like atomic waves, it can be heat, but this can also be a very, very tight spectrum, which is the visible light. And all the colors we can see there, this spectrum, and I think it's something like 350 nanometers to 700, something like that.
So it's very narrow bandwidth, but we have eyes where we're able to see that. We don't see wavelengths, we see colors. And these colors are a part of our human psychology. Not all animals perceive colors.
It is not necessarily that colors even exist, but they exist for us because the brain interprets these colors, these wavelengths more as colors. And we label it and we say, this is blue, this is yellow, this is red. It's not really there. It's just what we perceive. To be there. So this is for him a projection. It's how we perceive the outside world based on our own psychology.
Another factor of projection is that Jung says nothing is really empty. There's not really a void. Everything gets filled by the psychology and the unconscious. And I have another quote. Never do human beings speculate more or have more opinions than about things which they do not understand.
So when you have an empty well and it's just dark and you look inside, you don't see really the darkness. You don't necessarily see what is there. What you see and perceive is starting your own psychology and the own things that you interpret unconsciously into the world.
Let's say you're alone at home, you're sleeping in your bed, and suddenly in your apartment, your house, there's a loud noise. When you are an adult, you maybe have a certain expectation of what might happen. Something, appliance is broken down, maybe somebody knocked on the door and so on.
When you're rather a small child or when you're a frightful person, it could be like, oh, somebody's in the house. And when you're a child, you could even say, okay, there's a monster in the house, there's a witch in the house.
So the expectation is now, oh, there is something in the house and your brain automatically and your mind fills this blank void, this canvas of darkness with all these images of monsters, witches, burglars, or broken down houses. And it all comes automatically. And the same thing.
As Jung says something about opinion, if you don't have a clue about something, it's very easy to have an opinion. To have an opinion is not hard. It's very easy to have an opinion. He even says that like people don't think, they judge because it's easier. And it's true. It's easier to judge and have an opinion than really to explore something.
And very often this comes automatically.
And for him, he says that The dangerous thing is that consciousness is the sophisticated part that can differentiate, that can make a real investigation, that can really have, let's say, a scientific view with pro-contra arguments and be really differentiated in the worldview and even have complex thoughts.
But out of the unconscious is very, like, easy. And if consciousness believes everything that comes out of the unconscious, that makes consciousness pretty dull. But it's of course then again overwhelming.
I have another quote where he says, "Nature, the object par excellence, reflects all those contents of the unconscious which as such are not conscious to us. Many nuances of pleasure and pain perceived by the senses are unthinkingly attributed to the object without the pausing to consider how far the object can be made responsible for them.
And here's the thing: layer on top of reality. You have objects in the world, it's external. You have, you have a tree, you have a neighbor, you have a house, whatever. Those things are first and foremost free from judgment, free from value.
You as a human being and your experience, you bring in value in there and you have certain values that come on automatically from the unconscious. And if they're not questioned by consciousness, they're thought of like, yeah, I hate that neighbor or I hate that car or whatever. Can be taken completely at face value.
It's not really that it's— the hate is something that exists in the outside world. It's brought into through the perception and the experience of the undifferentiated consciousness. I have an example.
There's a psychological effect called the halo effect, and it's very often associated with if somebody has a positive trait, for example, somebody's tall, somebody has a symmetrical face, somebody's beautiful, somebody is a good athlete, good musician, good doctor, whatever, we tend to attribute to them more knowledge also in other fields.
And there has to be not really a relation between them. There has been no correlation between how good a musician is and what their views on politics are. But we associate those people get listened to and they get into talk shows and so on. That's a very interesting effect.
Like when you have salespeople, they're above average in height because they rather get hired as salespeople and are more successful as salespeople because it seems like people like tall people. It has nothing to do with whether they're good salesperson or not.
You have even the football players, American football, those who are more good looking, symmetrical faces, clear skin, good teeth. Clear eyes, all this stuff. They get higher paid and they get rather drafted than other people, even when their statistics— so it's very easy to measure the, the athletic performance— might be below average.
But they get into teams, they get sponsorship deals, all this stuff because they look nice, but they're not necessarily good football players. And there's an interesting movie about that called Moneyball with Brad Pitt. Where it's a struggling baseball team and he goes purely for statistics when he selects the players he wants to have because those people are cheap.
They may be not tall enough, they may not be beautiful, they maybe throw the ball in a weird way, so everybody is put off. But he looks like, okay, how far do they throw? How quickly can they run? So purely, let's say, objective, scientifically. And he hires all those people and he gets them dirt cheap and he suddenly becomes successful because he has a team of good players.
But this view, this halo effect that there are certain characteristics of a person that override everything else, it's extremely strong, extremely strong. Like other people cannot really copy it because they say like, yeah, but I really like this player. And they cannot maybe say why they like this player because Maybe they only like the teeth or whatever.
It, it then gets difficult to get out of one's own personality. And there's a second example. That's not the only spot where this has been done.
Also in British soccer, a couple of years ago, I think 6, 7 years ago, there was the football team of Leicester and they went like from the bottom of the list to winning because they did the same thing. They did Moneyball. They checked how people really are in their athletic performance. So it was amazing.
There was some guy, he made a tremendous load of money because he said they will win, and the odds were so high that they would not win. So, but this is just to explain the halo effect, and this is what is meant with there are certain characteristics that we project and values that we project on others and think we understand a thing or have grasped it in its completeness.
But we only have a very limited view. And if this view is very unconscious, not differentiated by consciousness and not integrated, this will always be, let's say, very primitive. This comes not from nothing. Like a projection needs a hook. You cannot— Jung says that you cannot project a genius into an ass. It's not, it's not possible. There has to be a relation.
And this is why he also says that the shadow is personified as the same sex of the person, because there's a hook. You are comparable. This is another man. I'm a man. This is a man. There's somatic comparison. Also with woman. Oh, there's another woman when I'm a woman. So there has to be a hook.
That there's enough resemblance, like a little bit ticking it off, that all the reaction can just— projection can stick to it. Of course, what can happen? You can incredibly become enthralled with certain objects because you're projecting all those unconscious contents on there.
And of course, it can be positive, there can be negative, but there can be a huge overvaluation of external objects. Something that needs to be broken down. And you have it in a lot of religions. You have it in Christianity, you have it in Buddhism to depotentiate the external world and more turn inward and have not this materialistic view.
And it's kind of projection breaking in that regard that it tries to remove this connection to outside things. Of course, if you have all your negative things and now you find a poor soul that you're projecting it on because there's the same sex, maybe they are similar to you, which is even worse.
This is then shifting the blame to that person. And Jung characterizes the main feeling with a shadow as hate. So hate is the main relationship feeling value that one has towards one's shadow.
Because deep down in the unconscious, maybe even consciousness, you know that this is something that should be integrated to you. It reminds you of yourself. And this is the stuff you try to repress. You try to keep it down hidden somewhere, but now it's all outside in the world.
And that is a way of the psyche that you confront your things, things you did not take care of, they're suddenly all around you projected because the psyche has this goal to make also consciousness grow bigger and grow larger because that's the goal. That's individuation. This is what, how one should live one's life.
So one is confronted with the situations that one needs to grow. So this means if you find something that you hate and have very strong negative emotions towards, there's something hidden there that you might have not taken care about yourself, something that you have not explored.
For example, when you have very industrious people and very conscientious people that work a lot and hard, what kind of people don't they like? Lazy people, people that don't do it because they see it more, let's say, relaxed. They don't see those things that, that people do so important. This is something also that one should learn.
And so it's a good indication, okay, go there where it hurts, like it's guilt, but it's also shame and it's hate. Of course, this is very bigly used in propaganda. I wrote in the description that evil always seems to lie on the other side of the Rhine.
I'm in Germany, I'm from West Germany, so the other side of the Rhine is France. And there's a big, there has been a big rivalry between France and Germany for a very long time, for hundreds of years. Or France and Great Britain, like it's always the neighbors fighting. And we also see it in Russia and Ukraine right now.
And the hometown where I'm from, which town gets hated the most? Ah, it's a town right next out of the town's border. So the next one. So you don't necessarily hate someone on the other side of the planet. No, you hate your neighbor. So, and it's this projection of all those negative feelings, negative attitudes. On somebody who's close, somebody who's available.
Jung described this also as his experience in Africa, where he traveled.
He traveled a lot to South America and to Africa and also to India to experience how people live more in hunter-gatherer societies, like pre-scientific societies, to have an immediate experience of the psychology of people, how people live basically for the whole time where people and human beings existed.
And he was there on a safari with some locals and they told him, ah, you, you can't go to the valley over there. It's horrible. The people there, they eat babies, they kill everyone. They just run around, uh, and gruesome and so on.
And He then went there with other people and of course everybody there was perfectly normal. It's fine. And he asked them like, okay, anything unusual here? And they're, no, no, everything's fine. But you know what? The valley over there, the people that are there, don't go there. They're horrible. They're horrible people. So it's this projection somewhere else.
And of course, in propaganda, this is used to find like a scapegoat for all those negative attitudes and yeah, basically the shadow. Putting the blame on other people just to not confront your own soul, which is also a quote by Jung that people rather change.
No, it's not. This is Solzhenitsyn. That people rather, or Dostoevsky, sorry, I'm mixing it up. But The quote is, people rather change the world than confront their own soul. And so also Nietzsche said like the line between good and evil runs through the heart of every man and woman.
And this is like, yeah, evil is also inside you. When one encounters the shadow and interacts with them. As I mentioned before, it's like the primitive ways. It's the old ways. This is not only because it's expression of the instinctual part of the psychology, but also because it's the things you have not taken care of.
It's the things that are not changed. Because Jung says things in the unconscious, they get preserved. So when you have trauma, bad experience, bad memory, all this stuff, It's like a wound that never closes because it's not healing. It's somewhere hidden away and there's always fresh, then can always come up and be like this experience again and again and again.
And it won't change until it's reflected upon. For him, that's integration into consciousness to find commonalities, to be accepting of that, to reflect on that and say, okay, What does it mean in context of myself? And in the unconscious, things are preserved.
Jung was a therapist, worked his whole life as a therapist. This is what he would do with people. He would talk with them about the things they would not accept about their own life, the things that they do incorrectly, because we have a moral function in our psychology that then acts up to say like, no, you're not doing it right. You're not acting in a correct way and manner.
So for example, he had one young man who was pretty smart and knowledgeable, but he had neurotic symptoms. So neurosis means that you're not really in harmony with yourself in your acting, how you want to do things. So like a neurosis can make you trip. Make you speak words that you did not want to say. The Freudian slip comes from there. And so it's just a disharmony.
You can sometimes see it in people. So like people who always get in accidents, their attention is diverted. They're not all horses pulling into the same direction. And the young man He was very knowledgeable about psychology and said like, I thought about everything my whole life.
And he talks about his childhood, his relationships, his family, and so on and so on. It's a good thing already when you can talk about it and when you have thought about all these different stages and all the aspects. And this went on for weeks and months. And Jung said like, okay, yeah, you're perfectly right. We now talked about Everything.
We talked about your whole personality, your whole experience, your whole life. I can't find anything. It's a mystery to me why you have a neurosis. And it was at the end. And the young man said, okay, good. Then I will go on to someone else, but first I will go on a vacation. And I will go to Italy or somewhere. And Jung says, okay, that's strange. You are a poor man.
You don't have a lot of money. How can you afford such a trip? And the young man says like, oh yeah, I have this friend, she's a teacher and she really likes me and she sends me money and I use that money to buy nice things for me and go on vacation and so on. And Jung says like, okay, have you thought about that? It's maybe not right.
Like, are you in a relationship with that girl? Is it family? Is it— No, no, we just met one time and now she's sending me letters and sending me money. I use it on myself. I tell him, maybe you should not do that. Maybe that's not the right thing to do. You should tell her to stop and to clarify what she's expecting of you.
Of course, he did not listen because that hit his shadow and his unconscious and all the repressed things he did not want to talk about. Then he went off thinking he's perfectly fine and has no problems because he did not see any problems because he did not want to see any problems.
Jung did not say what became out of him, but he mentions this story multiple times in the books as how it happens. Like when people become very disinterested in certain topics, like, oh yeah, no, no, this is not important. You can ignore us. We don't have to talk about it. I don't have to think about it. And because it's in the unconscious, it's unchanged.
It's like the primitive way. It's like It's always been done. I have one last quote for you, which is: Why do I say the shadow represents the old ways? The shadow is the inferior personality, the old personality, the easygoing thing. It is just your most personal reaction, the way you always have reacted.
For instance, you find the shadow in your personal resentments. Your intimate impulses, they are pretty much the same throughout your lifetime. And this is this aspect of— if you don't make the unconscious conscious, you will relive the same story again and again and will call it fate because you're trapped.
You're not developing in the sense that you're not integrating what should be integrating. So you have to learn the same lesson again and again. And the shadow is not an adversary. And you, oh, Star Wars was a perfect example, as you see.
And then in the second movie, that's in a vision, like in a cave, especially very Luke Skywalker goes into the unconscious, into a cave, and he encounters Darth Vader and he fights him and he kills him. But what does he find in the broken helmet?
He sees his own face, and this is already the realization that Darth Vader is closer to him and he's more part of Darth Vader than he likes to admit because they're going on the same path. They're both Jedi or Sith or whatever. And killing the shadow has no effect. It has to be integrated. So it has to be treated like a person.
Jung calls it diplomacy, dancing, or judo, to bring together and not to separate further because the separation is the, let's say, first thing that the consciousness does and wants to do. Like, oh no, everything is fine. I don't want to change because changing is extremely painful. It's not by accident called ego death.
The experience is similar. Then the old worldview and the old ego dies and has to be reborn by the ashes, like, like the phoenix. But it's just a normal way of how the psychology is supposed to evolve. And that's how the adventure of life should play out by integrating all those difficult things and pay attention and time to them.
And yeah, bring them home like a, like a good friend and always have them around and be aware of them. Of the things one, one is able to do and the things that one have experienced.
So this would conclude my presentation part, and I hope that you have now a better understanding regarding shadow and projection and how Jung used them and how he talked about them. And yeah, I want to thank you all. For your attention. It was a long talk. I did not plan to talk so long, but it turned out that way.
And yeah, this would conclude the presentation part. Thanks for listening.